unsurprisingly the creators gracefully
stick the landing and make a great
finale for this video I'll Reserve
talking about the overall season since I
want to do that in an upcoming video and
I'll put the emphasis on the finale for
this review now initially I felt a
little underwhelmed due to the
anticlimactic nature of the episode but
that's kind of the inherent nature of
where the season was going there was a
lot of setup as the war preparations in
this episode and we kind of get that
feeling of the battle drums starting to
play only for the season to end however
I think the creators did a good job to
offset that unsatisfied Feeling by
making an incredible Dragon Chase
sequence along with other aspects I'll
get into later the production value here
is literally unmatched by any show on
television and it's even wild to me that
the rings of power has a bigger budget
than this show and House of the Dragon
is still significantly better because
God damn the dragon cinematography dark
and rainy atmosphere and Landscapes
culminate to make an epic and immersive
experience variants for the finale the
entire chasing was imbued with so much
tension and Terror as we slowly realized
what is about to happen unless if you
were spoiled by the leaks like me but
even the foreshadowing of luceras
heading into a storm for his travels
tells the audience what is about to come
then the second he lands at Storm's end
and sees vegar we all knew we were in
for a treat emmentir is a gem of an
actor or should I say Sapphire and even
when he accidentally kills luceras he is
able to Showcase so much regret and
horror for what just transpired under
that malicious facade of wanting to be
menacing is still a human being that
realizes he went too far only for vegar
to go off the rails and go out of
eamon's control which the development
where the dragons disobey their Riders
adds another layer of complexity that
they aren't just weapons but creatures
with complicated feelings essentially
calling back to viscera saying that they
don't actually control dragons the idea
we control the dragons
is an illusion
so now the war is starting because
Granny vegar got sucker punched by
aracks and wanted some Revenge looking
at the cinematography of this scene it
was masterfully done as it showed off
the terrifying skill of Veigar as her
silhouette punches through the clouds it
made for an immensely scary experience
because any wrong move luceris makes
here will mean his death even the build
up to this Chase where he's frantically
trying to get out of there was
incredibly unsettling primarily due to
the fact that there was a raging storm
so visibility was limited as to where
vagar was just a perfect example of how
the setting AIDS the scene and even this
is contrasted when arax and luceris Fly
Above the Clouds giving us a sense of
relief just for it to be snuffed out
when Vigor comes in with her big
Chompers easily a top 5 scene for the
season and honestly I don't know how you
can make a scene have more tension than
that it was 10 minutes of pure
unadulterated anxiety on top of the fact
that in the back of our minds luceris is
kind of expendable to extent due to how
many children or Nera has so even when
he was in the throne room I was worrying
for his safety all Ament has to do is
crack a smile at luceris and I'd
immediately start running for the hills
so the fact that lucerus didn't
immediately turn around upon seeing
vegar was very brave despite it being a
major mistake on his part another aspect
that I loved within this episode is the
opposition between raniera and Damon
this kind of Harkens back to the episode
prior where there was terminal between
Otto and Allison it's a really
intriguing conflict when people on the
same side start to fight with one
another because you assume no matter
what they'll support each other but in
reality not everyone has the same exact
motivations and there'll be some
conflict and headbutting along the way
so seeing Damon being extremely horny to
kill some people and start a war and
that being contrasted with her near his
restraint was great character work it
really pains renera as a good leader
here and even when she seemed like she
was hesitating her intuition was
silverly strong the conflict between
Rainier and Damon also led to some
choking and I've seen some people get
mad at Damon for this but I mean it's
Damon that's definitely in character for
him since he's a lot more impulsive and
quickly swayed by anger and come on she
was blabbering on about A Song of Ice
and Fire again so she kind of deserved
it which is also a really weird point
for her to put emphasis on in terms of
motivationists not wanting to go to war
now I know it isn't just that but the
fact that the writers are including this
as a reason feels bizarre because it has
no relevance whatsoever to House of the
Dragon it feels like the executives at
HBO are forcing Ryan Connell to keep
making callbacks to the night king and
the prince who has promised because they
probably want to bring that all back in
the Jon Snow sequel show that they are
developing that's just my theory and I
can't think of any other reason why the
writers would keep bringing it up
because why keep setting this up when we
know as an audience that it doesn't have
payoff within House of the Dragon going
back to Damon he's a loose cannon who
does not have strong morals and having
that be contrasted with her Nera who
does makes for a good Dynamic it's just
immensely funny to me whenever Damon is
on the sidelines roasting Otto and
throwing in some insane quips that the
writers cook up only to act like a
disappointed child that he can't go on a
murder spree I also love how the
Dragonstone walkway scene was a mirror
to episode 2 where they confront Damon
about stealing a dragon egg it follows a
very similar scene progression where
Damon is quick to violence while ranera
is the one to defuse everything that's
an interesting point of comparison and
Otto as well gets to survive again this
man has balls of pure steel for going to
drag us on the face off against his
enemy twice next we should address the
miscarriage scene now I really enjoyed
this scene and even loved how the
writing kept stacking up stressful
elements culminating in an explosive
ending which chef's kiss but it felt
like a retread to go through these
motions again within this season we've
had four birth scenes assuming I'm not
forgetting any which that amount is
pretty insane on its own personally this
doesn't really bother me as much as it
does for other people from what I've
seen but with so many of these scenes I
feel like it lessens the impact of it
due to its frequency within the show
it's hard to say if they should have
removed one of them to make the
miscarriage seem more of a special event
but each of them requires such a
visceral performance from the actor that
the scenes are inherently jaw-dropping
the one birth scene story wise I'd
consider cutting would be raniera giving
birth to her third child in episode 6.
but even then the whole scene was a
runner and was extremely impressive at
the end of the day I don't dislike these
scenes and I think they were all done
very well besides maybe Elena's but I
can see why people would get upset by
this along with it being pretty graphic
even though this is a very mature show I
just hope going forward we ease off a
bit on the birth scenes because I think
we've had enough story wise I assume
there won't be any more or much more the
integration of it within this episode
was still good and I like how they were
squeezing in other scenes to ratchet up
the tension like Damon testing the
Loyalty of the kingsguard by bringing
out character's was a great moment I
especially love the shot where they
angled karaxi's head behind Damon's body
to show off the dragon's scale God the
cinematography in terms of dragon
coverage has been mind-blowing I don't
really remember any particular shots
within Game of Thrones that blew me away
but within this episode alone I was
getting floored by their presentation
even with Damon trying to tame that
Beast of a dragon which firstly great
vocals for Damon and secondly the dragon
revealing his size by breathing fire and
lighting up the room was an iconic
visual then the reflection in their eyes
was both two amazing shots and a good
story beat to punctuate them bonding
which I don't know if they specifically
bonded and if a dragon rider can have
more than one Dragon it would be pretty
weird if he's cheating on karaxi's but I
assume he's taming the dragon so someone
else can ride it makes me really thirst
for what future battles will look like
with all these massive dragons HBO is
going to have to crank up that budget
for the later Seasons at this race
and then lastly I love how much
attention they are putting towards
strategy like Damon immediately laying
out plans for defense and when you're
awaiting her options of all her allies
the types of scenes might not be loved
but I just find them so interesting
because of how detailed they are and how
much World building comes along with
them that and the Dragonstone map being
lit up by fire is a pure example of why
the production design and House of the
Dragon is a step up above Game of
Thrones I know that essentially boils
down to money but House of the Dragon
has been spending it really well then
Corliss comes out and I like how prior
to this scene they set up how Corliss is
not wanting to help rhaenyra but rainies
of all people is in support of her now
primarily because of her pure intentions
and not wanting to immediately start a
war similar to rainey's thought process
at the end of the last episode so this
essentially leaves a question mark as if
cordless will help renera when he shows
up because we don't know if the
persuasion from rhaenys made a
difference then that iconic Valerian
theme plays any triumphantly pledges his
support for her it was so uplifting and
was much needed because renero was down
bad overall a great end to an
outstanding season of House of the
Dragon this episode was so well balanced
in terms of tension conflict and moments
of relief where our heroes have a moment
of Victory just for it to end and leave
us with a cliffhanger as to what
reneer's wrath will look like now we
gotta wait one and a half to two years
feels bad man thank you for watching and
keep an eye out in the coming days from
My overall season review